this is a production of Cornell
University
okay thanks Jacob and sorry for them
mouthful of a title I shortened it a
little bit for here but oh well okay so
building off of what Evan said about
cassava already I'll just jump right in
some of the major cassava breeding
targets that the programs in the
next-gen group work on our pest and
disease resistance sorry about the I
need to figure out how to hold this
better okay
including CBS D or cassava Brown Street
disease this is the root on the left and
then cassava mosaic virus which is a
mosaicing on the leaf here yield and
field performance so the number of roots
per plant on the size of the roots shown
here and then quality traits and these
are all part of the selection indices
that are used by the breeding programs
today I'm going to focus mostly on this
quality trade part and the actual
measurement that's put into the
selection index is the root dry matter
content this is the percent of the root
that's not water and that's calculated
by the dry weight over the fresh wait
times hundred percent it's a major
component of the dry yield and the food
quality so it factors in to needs of
both processors farmers and consumers
it's typically ranges from twenty to
forty five percent with the higher the
better the twenty percent is not
something you'd actually want to eat or
grow and it's not uniform within the
root which is something I'll come back
to later the dry matter contents mostly
made up of starches carbohydrates with
some protein fiber ash lipids as well so
though it's so important for reading
programs it's time-consuming and
laborious to measure so in Uganda the
roots are graded by hand they're dried
in big ovens and when you consider that
there could be thousands of plots per
breeding program per season and limited
electricity that could make the ovens go
offline and then off-site trials that
you have to try
sport the roots back and forth that
creates a lot of work so the goal is to
reduce the amount of work that braiding
programs have to do each season and
that's where near-infrared spectroscopy
comes in and this has been used before
in cassava but I'll explain a little bit
about what it is so this is looking at
the reflectance in the near infrared
region of the electromagnetic spectrum
this is 780 to 2500 nanometers so just
beyond the visible it's measured by
using an active light source that emits
wavelengths in this range on a
biological sample and then the sample
itself changes the reflectance pattern
that's sensed by a sensor and so this is
what cassava looks like when you scan it
with a near infrared spectrometer so we
see reflectance on the y axis and
wavelengths on the X and this tells us
about the chemical and physical
properties of the sample that was
scanned but the signal that comes back
is complex and so it requires
multivariate statistical techniques to
decipher what's actually going on but
once you have models calibrated for the
traits of interest you can measure these
traits quickly and non-destructively so
like I said it's been used before in
cassava to look at dry matter content in
roots this has been done first of all
with the 6500 this is a benchtop model
that's been shown to be highly
predictive of dry matter content so
above 0.94 in the literature and then we
have a spectral range here that includes
some some of the visible range as well
from 420 580 meters the next generation
was from EK sorry Google Yahoo from John
Luke's lab and he looked at this mobile
spectrometer the quality spectra it has
an even larger spectral range but the
predictive ability dropped a little bit
in his tests to 0.8 which is still
pretty good and it passed the standards
for breeders but the problem with these
two units is they're really expensive
and for a small breeding program this
might be way out of the budget you could
extra workers you could put extra field
plots do more trials for this amount of
money so for these reasons we've been
looking into the CEO which is a small
hand handheld spectrometer that's only
three hundred dollars per unit but it
does have a smaller spectral range and
this this means that we need to evaluate
the performance of the spectrometer
before we can fully recommend it to
breeding programs in order to do that we
collect calibration data so scans from
the spectrometer paired with these oven
measurements that I was talking about
before we use those as input for
prediction model development and once we
have models that pass our standards we
can use them routinely in breeding
programs but to get to that point we
need to optimize the protocols that
we're using both in actual sampling of
the roots and in model development and
then we do need to keep going back and
making sure that our models are still
appropriate as our populations change we
have three generations so the
calibration data collection looks like
selecting several routes for plot and
then slicing them so this you have three
different slice points and that is that
is so that we can cover the variation
within the route these route slices are
each scanned with the spectrometer and
then we take a mean plot dry matter
content measurement using the oven
method that I talked about earlier and
these scans are paired with these
measurements and those go into our
prediction models so these are the
populations that I've been working with
so far the dry matter content varies
pretty widely both within and among both
trials and breeding programs I want to
point out a couple things here first is
these two trials a timber Appa and
Brazil are seedling evaluation trials
and if you talk to any cassava breeder
you'll know that seedling evaluation
trials from true seed are not always
indicative of what the plant will
actually do when you take a clonally a
clonal probably from it so we see a wide
range of dry matter content in those two
these two trials from my ITA are
actually the same genotypes grown in two
different years so we do see a lot of
variation due to environment here and
then this trial at nakri is has a low
tail here for dry matter content and
that is because of CBS d incidents in
Uganda so that's those disease routes
from that first slide that I showed and
that really affects the dry matter
content of okay so once we have these
oven dry matter content measurements
paired with our scans we can use those
to create prediction models so I divide
them into training and test sets and
then use five fold cross validation and
partially to tune partially squares
model parameters with the training set
and then use the optimized model to
predict our training star test set I
output model performance statistics like
R squared root mean squared error and
then I repeat this with different
subsets of training and test sets so
when we look at performance within
breeding programs so that's the diagonal
this is not a correlation matrix it is a
training set on the y-axis test set on
the X this is whole breeding program
performance so we can see up in the top
left is using AIT a data to predict AIT
a data and then so on so this is in 2018
we see that model performance is pretty
high we got a 0.85 r squared with a 2.6
our MSE for i-i-i-t a and then going
down there but the real test would be to
see how the models perform when your
training on one breeding program and
testing another so can we train models
at iit a and test them in rwanda say
answer is mixed back we have some models
doing really well like using the
improper data to predict the plots at
nakri but then when you use iit a we're
getting poor performance predicting
either of the other breeding
programs this is a little concerning but
again we could just train models for
each individual breeding program ideally
though we would use everything we have
and training like a major model and then
use that to test everything and so when
we do that we actually see the
performance go back up which is pretty
great so this is really comparable to
this diagonal here we only lose a very
small amount of our predictive ability
but in order to make these big models
using everything we have we have to be
able to put everything together in one
place
so this is where cassava base comes in
I've been working with Lukas Mueller's
group to create the infrastructure to
store an access spectral data within
cassava base this will allow for us to
take training and test sets from any any
trial within the database and then use
them to build and evaluate models so the
functions that I've been writing and
using from my own work we're putting
into cassava base for use by any breeder
and then they can build evaluate their
own models and use them for prediction
and then the predicted value is can be
used for selection in the selection
indices I've been talking about so
that's our plan moving forward but I'd
really like to thank all of the next-gen
cassava breeding programs Gore lab the
pheno apps team my committee and then
the funding from the Vino apps project
so that I'll take questions yeah Evan so
by combining - you mean two programs or
yeah so um here what I did is trained on
two programs and like 70% of the third
and then tests on that 30% hold out so I
haven't tried training a model on say
IIT and a Korean predicting Embrapa but
that's definitely something that I could
do yeah so for here I'm just training it
on the spectra but I do have a test
plots from all of the environments
included in the training set so I also
have done cross validation schemes that
hold out an entire environment or
specific genotypes and those as you'd
expect perform a little more poorly than
these do yeah it is pretty exciting
yeah so the question was could I subset
the data from the spectrometers with a
larger range to my smaller range and
compare how they do compared to this one
yes we actually did that before starting
with Lugo's data is take a subset from
740 to 1070 nanometers which is the
Visayas range and saw pretty high
performance I don't remember the exact
numbers at the top of my head but in the
high point eats for dry matter content
we we also looked at carotenoid content
for that and so it was as expected
pretty low because most of the signal
for carotenoids is in the visible range
which is outside the range of the SIA so
that's why we went ahead and moved
forward with the dry matter content
thank you are there any questions over
zoom okay well thank you very much Jenna
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu